a great time to be an architect I hope
to convince you of that there's very
much exciting work to do
we don't get any free lunch anymore by
the way I'm happy to be here I was here
for five years of grad student then I
switched over to the dark side that's
Berkeley turns ugly the dark side is
actually good as well so now I'm kind of
torn but scooting back and I'm gonna
talk to you about architecture work that
we do at Lawrence Berkeley Lab along
with dileep who's in the audience and
first I'd like to start because rich
mentioned the 2x every 18 months like to
start with a quick poll what do we think
dr. Moore actually said because I've
heard all of those things three things
that I show you in my slide effort to X
every 12 months 18 months or 24 months
it changed we changed from what was 18
to 24 so dr. Martinez never actually had
18 as far as I know he said 12 initially
1965 and then revised it to 24 but I've
heard that 18 as well I'm not sure why I
don't know if I'm missing something or
just because people average out 12 and
24 just but cut a feature in half but 3
L is the density finding inverse square
law you used in quite revolts when you
have linear distance and I've actually I
made drawn masks back nearer before of
spice so it's an inverse square okay
tell you the time scale you want me to
read it I actually have the verbage at
night for 1965 in my database
it was revived yes that was definitely
white I approximately 10 years after
that you know it was it was a very good
ride we had 40 years of pretty good
scaling you can see like whoo 1970 all
the way to 2020 the short future
expectations of 2027 we had the whole
array of technologies and scaling
factors come up maybe we'll get 50 years
not 50 years more but 50 years old so we
might have a little more to go
and it was good well lasted we had you
know pretty good properties that came
out with every technology course it was
decreasing feature size was decreasing
as well but at some point you know this
is getting smaller and smaller and we
were getting into the atomic scale so
that makes things harder Moore's law was
also like it was a technical economic
argument so scaling might stop because
of fundamental technology limitations or
because of economic limitations we don't
know with the different minister to
which will happen first but one of those
two boom it will stop scaling it hasn't
happened yet but expectation is it will
happen soon and by the way along with
Moore's law of scaling the source of
most of documentation documentation has
also been increasing with every feature
shrinking it's because of everything
every new technology being smaller
there's more restraints it's it gets
more complicated to manufacture but
scaling has been slowing down there's
already evidence of that Intel had the
famous tik tok model where at every
generation that would change the process
the technology and then the next time
around it would change the architectures
and go back now they went to the tik tok
tok model i i don't think they call it
that where they change the process once
and then they change the architecture
twice so now they spend more time with
the architectures because the process
has been not scaling us as fast so
really what we're trying to do here is
this is Moore's law of the past and this
is like morsel of the near future or
recent past at some point it's gonna end
2025 is a possibility we don't of course
know exactly when but somewhere along
this timeframe what we're really trying
to do is to use architecture as well as
other new devices new materials new
other technologies that they'll be
talking about to keep the form scaling
going on even when there's traditional
transistors have stopped their scaling
so how do we make it happen I'm what
kind of emerging technologies do we have
in our arsenal
I'm going to scaling scaling performance
in this case really because well what's
trying to increase here is is
performance even though resistor feature
sizes stop scaling yeah yeah it's
performer scaling so I'm really what we
have in our arsenal to keep this
performer scaling going is emerging
transistors and I'm gonna be talking
about all these memories 3d integration
specialization with various formula that
takes and there are other technologies
that I'm not going to be talking about
today today like photonics and others
there's just too many options but the
thing that main four players are at the
four that it just showed but you know
the title of this talk is really an
architect's point of view and how do we
use all that in the architecture how do
we make sense out of all these options
so before we answer that let's remember
what architects do right what's our job
as architects and architects just to
take a bunch of pieces Legos right and
they put them together in clever ways
and they come up they design something
they design something that makes sense
that this functional that is optimal in
some metric like strength or beauty or
you know however you want to find this
particular building but that is really
what what we're doing and we've been
forcing it so far that the pieces by
themselves have been getting better and
better better so if we use them in the
same way we come up with a better result
but now we're gonna have to come up with
something we think you design a new
methodology to keep this improvement
going on so let's assume that you know
to continue with this that we've been
fortunate in the Lego world to have
better and better designs just from
better pieces same pieces but despite
the qualities we've been getting from
small designs to medium designs to even
skyscrapers and we've been using the
same as mythology that we'll be using
same pieces just the pieces were getting
better but at some point the old designs
or the old LEGO pieces can no longer
keep improving so now let okay MUP with
this new four different pieces
and they're all different and they all
promise to keep the improvement of this
building of new buildings keep going on
so we want to use them but it's not as
simple as to just look at each one
individually and figure out what they're
good at we have to evaluate them at the
context of the entire building of what
we're making we have to answer questions
like what
how does using each of one of these
change the design how do we and how does
each one of these are using which one of
these changes how we use each other's
other pieces so as well as the ones we
used to have and when we make this
evaluation at the building scale in this
case how do we give feedback to the
manufacturer to change this to keep our
performer scaling going on so our legos
in this case of course are the four
pieces that they show you before
starting with emerging transistors
there's actually a plethora there are
many many devices many new transistors
that are being manufactured broadly what
we can cut through grass and most new
designs or new materials there are many
examples of each now the problem with
with evaluating a new transistor is that
many of them take time to show that
they're promised right if if technology
and this is by the way this graph that
I'm showing here is a pretty generic
graph with many kinds of technologies it
applies here as well because we have a
mature technology in this case MOSFET
technology a that is pretty good where
we are now a new technology coming alive
I mean being developed takes time to
show its promise
so we're errant right now a technology B
that neut resistors that's going to
replace most of it it's it doesn't
necessarily look good as good as a
MOSFET but we have to judge this
potential the problem is that there's
not one B there are many B's there's
tens or twenty B's so and we have to to
make a predicted guess by evaluating B
in the context of the architecture or
the system to figure out what the
winning transistor will be of course it
might not even be that simple because we
might have more than one B's in the end
we can have a one transistor for
different one application one for a
different application or different
environment
there's as a certain beginning there are
many many devices here I'm showing here
a graph we see energy and delay of not
even all just as some transistors that
being worked on some of them are exotic
if I can use it were like spintronics
that they represent like a bus in
different design others are usually this
is the same material that we have right
now just a different design like like a
tunnel FETs and all of these are moving
targets because they're improving it's
they're not static each of these has you
know many smart people behind them
they're being developed being active
actively pursued and we have to make
sense out of all these options in the
end the architecture scale how do we use
them
how does using each one of them change
the architecture and how does how do
these interact with each other so that's
just from the devices on the memories
part on the memories front there's also
many many memories as well I don't
expect you to read everything part of
this table but the point is on on each
column here is a memory technology and
there's not there's more than shown here
there's the traditional ones like SRAM
theorem so on flash and there's some new
ones like resistive Ram SDRAM there are
others I don't show them as well and
there are bunch of properties for each
one like how long does it take to read
them to write them the energy to do that
as well Power Cell size and you know
while the good the new memories are
pretty good that many things are not
great at everything they're good at some
things and not as good at others so some
of them are better at reading than
writing for example or vice versa so we
have to make sense of how to use all of
these options again in the memory
hierarchy and another very interesting
opportunity for is that some of these
memories are non-volatile so they can
retain their data after we part them
down which traditionally has been like
far away in the memory I agree but now
it's getting getting closer so if we
look at the memory hierarchy it's sort
of traditional what we have right now we
have registers caches there are some
sort of flash maybe
destroy tape right now we have memories
memory technologies that are
non-volatile but there is cheapest DRAM
or cheaper or fastest theorem maybe they
don't take this much energy so now the
flash of the non-volatile part is moving
up it's also physically moving closer
because I'm gonna talk about 3d pretty
quickly so now we're going to have all
these memory technologies really close
to the computing course so what does
this mean for caches do with the only
caches or Flash's were all even theorems
there are many open questions there but
the point is that these new memories
combined with 3d might change the memory
hierarchy to a large degree and that is
also something that we need to explore
we need to answer 3d especially deep 3d
has been enabled by advancement of many
other technologies so d30 is an example
that what I'm showing here we have all
these yellow layers are computing layers
they can be general-purpose like some
sort of core or they can be accelerators
or GPU something more specialized and
those are interleaved in again in this
example there are other ways of doing it
with storage non-volatile memory some
sort of memory technology that I showed
you before like resistive Ram it is
non-volatile and now this has been is
increasingly being enabled by many other
technologies like fine grain through the
integration so now we don't need vs we
can have more bond with a cheaper
communication between layers and it's
also being enabled so if you if you look
at this construct if you make this very
very deep one problem that jumps out is
hidden to the right it's harder to hit
this because at it's very core it's
gonna generate lot of hits harder to get
it out well but if we use transistors
and memory that are less power-hungry
then we can we have less of a hit
density problem it's still gonna be
there by the point is using in this
particular example either carbon
nanotubes which is a device example or
resistive ROM which are which have less
power it's going to enable us to make
this deeper it's higher
so this is an example of how they
interact but even if we just look at
these contracts remember what I showed
what they mentioned before about memory
now we can have memory right next to the
computing layers and we can have high
bandwidth communication between computer
layers so the assumption that memory is
far far away and getting to it is
expensive is might not no longer be true
very soon we can also have different
kinds of memories at different layers
yeah this is I have I have a box white
box lying here to show you the very end
of something like this that was
manufacturing with carbon nanotubes so I
wouldn't say it's manufacture but at
least in a high in a large scale just
yet but it's getting there yeah I'm I'll
I'll show you yeah but but remind me
because it's about a flight all the same
yeah okay so so that's 3d and then the
specialization which refers to a whole
bunch of things actually specialization
is really what it means is that we're
exploring the trade-off between
programmability and low overhead so if
you think of that of general purpose
core like the arm core x86 core there's
a lot of overhead power and lady C
involved there just to make it
programmable and there's a good reason
for that but there's still a lot of
overhead if we start giving up some of
that overhead let's make say for example
make it partially programmable then we
might become get something like a GPU
and if we keep getting exploring that
overhead to make a piece of hardware
that is not programmable but it does
only one thing but that's the thing
really really well that's a fixed
function Hardware we can build an ASIC
like a new RTL block that does for
example FFT only does a 50 there's a
specific way to communicate to it and
for input and get the results out but
it's really good at they're doing FFT so
this is the C of accelerators idea it's
one of the possible strategies to have
many of the small accelerators in future
chips because we can have a lot of
silicon
and yeah and then of course with GPUs
apart programmable mention that and then
there's another exciting opportunity
where's this which is FPGAs how we we
can use them put them next to general
computation course even dynamically
reconfigure them on on the fly there's a
whole bunch of spectrum when I'm talking
about specialization again it's another
architectural study or or something we
can explore what I like to stress here
is two things first is that the variety
and it choices that we have is
overwhelming each I talked about four
things only devices I didn't even touch
photonics and each one of these has a
lot of options and each of these options
is interacting with each other the
choice of a device might change how we
do 3d for example or how we're designer
accelerator anytime we have so many
options it's hard to come up with a good
design manually or at least an optimal
design by symmetry that by itself I
think it's going to be a problem the
other problem is that if we have a new
transistor and let's focus on the
resistors or devices typically people
who manufacture or design them they
value them at a device scale so they
look at the transistor something like
spice or the physical simulation maybe
they're going to look at a small circuit
but really what we want to do is
evaluate that resistor into the
architecture how that's gonna fit in
build a processor that's good for the
traditional designer so they can find
you in their design but it's also good
for the architects so we know how to use
for example at the the tunnel fit to
resistor how what that's gonna do to the
architecture is it going to increase
parallelism is going to increase is it
gonna make the chip less reliable or or
any other input that's going to have and
of course we're gonna move from the
architecture to the system that
transition isn't easy partly because the
tools aren't there to a large degree and
of course yes and also didn't want to
neglect the software aspect of it which
my talk is not gonna be a program
ability but that is a really important
problem it's even just for
specialization how we help programmers
use these accelerators is a big problem
because history has shown that if
something is not easy to use for program
might not even be used or it might not
be used well so program build is another
problem that really needs to be valued
at high scale in architecture or system
for devices that are being generated now
and again especially well not especially
but firstly things like programmability
it's good to get a head start build this
tool so we can evaluate program ability
for devices that we don't have yet in
real silicon in products because by the
time we have them we already want to be
able to program them ok so how do we
make an architect's job easier and how
do we navigate through that landscape
really what we want to be able to do is
we want to be able to write it something
like this I'm showing you an example of
a heterogenous chip where there's CPU
there's two accelerators there's a
memory M ROM there's a memory
accelerator as well
acceleration is not only about
computation it can also be about memory
access and some of these are implemented
with different devices because it's
optimal to do so so we want to be
devided something like this at the
architecture scale so we can ask the
questions like how do we design
accelerators better where do we put them
how the devices change those assumptions
so on but in order to do that evaluation
at the at the architectural level we
have to start at the transistor and and
train models to evaluate a simple logic
block like another train models to go
see we're going up higher levels of
abstraction right now by training models
every time we go up and the third level
evaluate a simple block like a processor
or or or an accelerator using the
transistor models of of the first level
whether that's so we start the work with
resistors train train train increase
abstraction go up and eventually reach
the architecture level I'm gonna get
that I think it's gonna be clear yeah
when I put it here so if this is
basically showing the same four levels
of instruction that I told you right now
first level is device the second level
simple logic blocks third level
synthesis RTL very logs it could be more
complex logical memory and that the
fourth level is is architectural level
so cheap level simulation and an entire
chip multiprocessor what I meant by
train is when we have a new transistor
something comes up with with an interest
or anyone evaluated at the architecture
level they're gonna give us a physical
representation array a physical model
that's going to go to the first level
where we have a single transistor we're
gonna use that single transistor model
to build a simple circuit like an other
both of this level in this example is to
set is are handled by spice but spices
doesn't scale very well we're gonna go
hop to entire chip level so we're going
to construct maybe that's a better word
shade we're going to construct a model
to connect levels two and three in this
case it's a technology library file so
we're gonna need a technology library
file and train in that sense the third
level so the third level can have
synthesized using RTL so we plug in very
log octal or any other cell that we want
and that level is going to synthesize
using the the models that were generated
from the first two levels so we let me
put it at different ways first level is
going to generate a technology library
file that now says hey I can build a
gate and I'm Gator on or gate or an
inverter using the 33 you gave me T FET
or something and we're gonna use that to
synthesize any sort of very log and sort
of logic block does that make sense in
terms of train yeah it's not much in
there I didn't mean to put it like yeah
yeah yeah exactly so so we go from a
physical
so a little higher abstract model so
that we can run something more more
complex something larger and then so
that's the third level the fourth level
is a chip level simulation and that's
the entire chip and now we use a
behavioral simulator which has models
that we generate from the previous
levels and I'm gonna by the way this is
the paradise to flow that we are
building it's an opera source to flow
and it's able to go from from the system
level to the chip level the point is if
somebody comes up with a new technology
we're gonna put it through the flow so
we can evaluate it at the chip level so
to illustrate a little more what I was
talking about is the first two levels
have said this physical simulation where
we can design something simple like
another two bits in this case and we can
get waveforms we use size which is an
open source spy simulator physical
design again and this example what we're
showing is we use it and we're showing
an other using town fat so like a new
transistor in physical simulation in
this simple circuit now for the next
step oh and and and before I move there
we can using just the first two levels
we can actually run interesting
experiments already other's levels so
just that so here I show you how how we
compare and other the top left
multiplier and bottom left and a matrix
multiplier between three transistors
actually 4 seamers down fed the carbon
and you fed and negative capacitance fed
the these three graphs are delay the
bottom right graph is power so we can
already compare this fortunate resource
in terms of simpler logic blocks address
and multipliers and we can see here for
example that that carbon nanotubes and
and negative capacitance feds are doing
much better in terms of latency and
power then seamless but it's good to
quantify those those things so but to
take it one step higher now if we want
to evaluate another are wider either or
a more complex circuit we have to go to
the RTL level the RTL level now
synthesis is very long and uses the
technology that we characterize
from previous level so here what I'm
showing is a comparison of another from
8 to 24 2014 8 bits that's the x-axis in
terms of delay in the y-axis and we
compare CMAs versus T fed on what's
basically the critical path through that
other as it gets wider and that's done
at the RTO level so we can synthesize
with very log 4 for talentfits
which is at register again that that was
characterized physically but it doesn't
really it's an emerging technology and
we can run other interesting results so
here what we've done is we've compared
negative negative pastures feds and
carbon and two threats with first
designs against other published work
this was to verify our own work but also
to run the same experiments for more
complex designs so we have V scale which
is various five core for example we have
two accelerators down here and we have
another and an ALU and our two flow is
did pretty well but it's interesting to
see how quickly and easily we can do
these comparisons we only did the RTL of
a V scale processor in this case and we
use it technology file that we generated
from from the physical layers and last
level is the architectural level where
we use Jim 5 that's basically behavior
level and it's a cycle iCard behavioral
simulator for internship jim 5 is but
basically uses a power model it collects
events how many structures were executed
how many times the memory was accessed
as well and it touches those events to a
memory and - I'm sorry - an energy cost
that we generated from the lower levels
so Saints same with computations so now
we can tell Jim 5 hey every each of
these events will cost you that much
energy because we characterize it in
spice and an RTO here what I'm showing
you is a very simple study of how the
choice of transistor changes the impact
of the of an accelerator to the
application so now we're on actual
application code that uses an
accelerator and we measure the
difference that
that that makes the depending on how we
implement that accelerator with whether
it's a seamless or tea fit in this case
because the accelerator was kind of
small in size it didn't really matter it
did I mean they didn't have any
particular it was very small whether we
use the tea fat or kind of or CMAs but
that's the kind of study that we want to
be able to do with different sizes of
accelerators and that's something we're
also actively working on to expand it
and make it make this accelerators
larger and with different resistors so I
presented a whole bunch of tools which
are great I mean generating tools is
great but it's also good to use them to
to come up with conclusions and ideas
and and the user for something useful I
did mention at the beginning that the
amount of choices that we have is
overwhelming by itself because there's
many options and different kinds and
they interact with each other so maybe
it's a solution to that this is more
into the research part of it this is
just representing ideas is something
like this where what I'm trying to show
here is an automated design methodology
for an architecture so let's take it
step by step
yeah we also have negative buttons fits
here as well but those those three are
the three that we've started with they
look I mean there's we make it easy for
people to add their own device and and
run this experiments themselves but we
didn't run through everything now yeah
so I'm not saying that Seafarer the CM
FET is the best among all yes
okay so ultimate designer those use of
architecture so really the grand idea of
what we're doing here is we're trying to
come up with an automated way using all
the technologies that we have to design
a piece of hardware that is good at some
application and for some metric that's
why it is the left part of the slide are
the inputs the inputs number one is the
application
and characterizing application is a big
problem by itself right but even simple
metrics like bytes per flop or whether
that application uses floating-point
that by itself can be an an important
input to the optimization methods we saw
here the second input is the available
technologies so this matrix here is it's
basically saying hey you can use any of
C most effective infinite and svet those
four transistors as an example these
memories these specialized are
architectural in other words these
accelerators that we've designed and as
well as some other variables basically
these matrix here is represents
technologies that we've characterized
using the tool flow that I showed you
before so now we know how they perform
the delay their power at large and small
scales so again the inputs are
technologies and application based on
those inputs we can run through and by
characterizing the application and we
can run through an optimization method
that's part of the researcher had to do
it whose job is to select okay from
those technologies that you have as
valid options you should choose
accelerator number one the could be a 50
you choose an M Ram and you choose an NC
fat why because they're good for the
particular application and the last step
now that we have we know what to use we
can further tune that by metrics so if
you care about performance of you care
by power of you care about performance
over power the design might change but
the design that came that comes out will
be a complete architecture of what
accelerators to use what cores what
devices just because the number of
options is so large so this could be a
way forward further making architecture
design more optimized more automated and
more formalized another way another
interesting use of the tool and another
thing that come up might come up in the
future is if we look at the FPGAs we're
going to have any devices in FPGA as
well it's not gonna be just a six so
mapping
piece of logic into an FPGA used to be
straightforward pretty much like be roms
and and lots and so on
we have new devices in the in and FPGA
they're gonna be more heterogeneous so
mapping them might not be so easy so I
wait for word something else we're
working on is what we call Casper where
basically after characters in code and
finding what parts of the code we can
actually do it within the FPGA we take
that through a formulation where we
construct a graph and then we map the
the groups of the computation groups
that come out of this graph basically
the types of computations that that
application has to do we map that with a
mapping step to the actual hardware
different piece of computation or better
should suit it for different parts of
the FPGA based on what devices are in
the FPGA so we're trying to come up with
that without mapping here further so
when we talk about quantum computers
they're new they're exciting we talked
about qubits they're all great but a big
part of making Quantic need to happen is
the digital hardware that goes around it
now there's digital hardware at the
input so a sample system has an FPGA
that that drives a wave maker that
actually drives the qubits and the
output of the qubits code the digitizer
to convert back visual logic and then to
a computer for processing it's it's as
we scale and have more and more qubits
we need more and more of these logics of
this digital control logic and if we if
we actually get to a thousand cubits
that the big question by itself right
but that number is thrown out referred
or kind of computer if we took a two
thousand cubits we're gonna have like
billions of operations per second to
process in digital hardware that's huge
right that that is that's that's a
problem and I've talked to quantum
experts and they say that a lot of the
time that they spend is actually
spending the digital part of quantum
computing so we don't want to be in a
place where quite a digital computing is
constraining quantum in any shape or
form whether that's performance or power
of course so by using a to flow like I
talked about we can generate and we can
generate and
sort of a specialized architecture for
quantum using your devices to make this
problem a little better because it's
going to become it's going to become a
big problem also and a possible answer
to new device and neither this ray or
the Moore's Law question is super good
luck technology superconductors this is
like the highest level overview of what
how that looks like from a distance
pected if we have the sort of
traditional curve where we have
temperature and with more temperature we
get more resistance it's a nice curve so
because dr has basically zero resistance
at up to certain temperature and that's
the property that these line of work is
trying to take advantage of resistance
basically to zero if we operate in this
regime here we can have hundreds of
gigahertz and deep pipelines and that's
gonna change the architecture now
because now we have really deep
pipelines also memories a grand
challenge because now we're making the
gap between computation speed and memory
access speed even wider
all right so alleviating that it's gonna
be a big challenge and there's gonna be
a lot of impact to D at the other parts
of the system as well if we if we use
superconductors this is just some
there's also more questions that are
really relevant into the future of
architecture I we talked about you know
which device technology will dominate
and what computation weights will
dominate what side effects would have
rely build is a big possible side effect
for instance how does architects will
change with device technology how do we
design an accelerator or a core if we
dirty fed versus a carbon nanotube how
do we pay take advantage of this 3d and
how do we handle the memory hierarchy
changing where do we put accelerators
how far away do we put them how large do
we make them do with making a small fine
grain for smaller 50s or larger parts of
the program how does the memory
hierarchy change and then how do how do
Janus two architectures become or how to
header genes do we want them to become
based on how hard it is to schedule and
use them and as I said programming is a
big part of this channel
if we build a tool that performs
architectural simulation for a platform
that we're gonna get one day we don't
have a programmers can use that and
build runtime and compilers based on
that how the program is used
non-volatile memory efficiently now that
non-volatile memory will come close to
logic how about the heterogeneous memory
carriage even more that we have before
like a deeper hierarchy or maybe how
about a shadow how do we reconfigure
accelerators if we have an FPGA that we
can use on die how do we make that how
do we use that and how do we deal with
reduced reliability there's an
approximate computing is out there is
it's a good idea for some domains but it
might become more important for
resistors that are less reliable so many
questions not many answers there are
some answers but there's still a lot of
work to be done it's it's a really good
time to be an architect because now we
have opportunity to solve all these
questions just with architecture not
just waiting for the next iteration of
device technology and it's hard to
predict how a digital could be this
going to be it's going to look like in
20 years but it's a good time to focus
on a grand strategy to make sense out of
all our options and figure out how to
keep going forward one year later okay
yeah now but but there are some
important questions and I mean it's
going to take a long time to answer them
and me coming from you know the
high-performance computing world as well
it's sort of a different flavor but
there are many challenges that I shared
with datacenters and general purpose
computing so I can take questions I can
also show you that slide so this is what
was built it was the n3xt system it was
a published paper
professor meter was what was part of
this as well so it's sort of local work
in that sense they showed huge
improvements from 10 X 2,000 X and then
G delay
depending on the kind of on the kind of
application it wasn't exactly what I
showed you in the sense that there
wasn't so much interleaving of memory
and logic but it was still there were
there was logically I'm trying to
remember the details myself there were
the logic layer was at the border with
general purpose course and then there
was a memory layer 64 gigs yeah yes was
clear so it's basically a logic caching
memory but even with that they were able
to demonstrate a lot of benefits of
course some of that were from carbon
atoms themselves others were from 3d and
having all this stacking this was
actually built like you know not even
oil you might be loose it was a
demonstration but all this capability
was in one block or just a theoretical
prediction of what was possible is
showing the overall view of the next
system you'd see at the bottom there so
that's their vision and an actual build
model was again a 3d model which
pattered
on a five stage pipeline risk it has
another motorcycle actually fabricated
shown here CMOS a silicon layer was
there CN fit layer was there also they
had a third layer called a sensor since
are they're basically application they
focused on that was a gas sensor
application so this five stage pipeline
architecture will classify the type of
gases being sensed at the top layer of
is 3d designers and approximately how
many transistor equivalence did it
contain total if that's an appropriate
question but it's a nature publication I
can point you later
what was it Leslie trillion listener
trillion okay did it have 64 gigabytes
upon ship parameters listening oh no
this this it's okay so that what I guess
not
it's not the gates though so over our
next three system okay like what
George is mentioning is actually they're
pretty cheap has been fabricated and how
many transistors are on that money few
million transistors money yes let's do
the details later but there was a
demonstration well that's okay but it
was a nature permutation yeah SSD detect
it was Tiffany out there this is
astonishing if they've actually built it
how much of it is real I mean I don't
have any numbers on that it was a little
smaller scale version of this but it was
so if I don't this could I keep it cool
well and scale that that was built it
was now that full scale I tighten up
i I don't know because I I don't know
how I mean the the power characteristics
I'm sure you could if you made some
sacrifices right with with how it's been
used and and the utilization factor but
there are or or by using the right
memory technology right a big lengthy
factor of Tippa 3d is exactly heat
density right so so it's not really a
question of if we if we build this how
can we call it is how can we change it
to cool it right what can we use to make
this feasible and this is one of the
questions one of the holes in there so I
want some I guess it's one way of doing
it yeah actually amazing number of
architectures Denver returned all using
a version with firmer you know nobody
that cooling pipes anymore they just
dunk it all it werner there was not see
the demonstration somewhat a thing in SC
this year
we're exactly as they thought old boards
and yeah I'm just saying it was pretty
incredible
having a little duck slowly nodded oh
yeah and they were both coming out on
board as it is in Crete you don't miss
yeah yeah they did about two dozen of
those but no everything that pretty does
these days is is it for her I mean it
drop the price with Werner for 15,000
dollars a gallon to $200 a gallon but
now period the people who really do this
stuff they they've gone beyond inversion
yeah I mean even with that make it to
things still gonna be an issue I would
still have to find yeah what we can do
but here's what you're also looking at
electronic stooge only right neurology
at photons as an example I stay well we
had the only vegetable material yeah
we're not looking at the photos although
that is something that could play in
here but I worked as a base will model
photons yeah what machines well there's
different people who took quantum I mean
we see the waves as a separate price not
that replacement for for digital another
replacement for a big part of the HPC
world so they're good at what they do
but they don't do everything yes my
friends would have one well yeah I mean
I really say sir is he keep the exchange
problems it turns out if you have oxygen
in the water yeah it's a real mess and
it's also not easy to program as well as
schedule and everything it's yeah I mean
there when did those that our problem
with the d-wave and I think quantum in
general I mean there's there's many
ambitions on scaling up and go 2,000
cubits but how many do we have yet right
we have tens so so we'll see where that
goes but you see these things where
people a VC grow the pure industry
analysis buddy consumer market
yeah I mean who other than the NSA has
been a paper
exotic technology
well so the do II you know cares about
HPC and scaling up and we think we're
gonna get exascale with the technology
that we have right now but I'll be your
next skill we need to do something
different so think the DOA is can
occurrence they starting to care
DARPA released a program for force more
flavor the air I that was back in
November thing the NSA the NSF is
starting to so there are many agencies
that are really young well that is a
problem yes but that is but they still
show summer I mean I think the dog was
called like 75 million or something
that's nothing no no trust me anything
has vastly more than that I agree just
even that for us good but Wall Street
what will they pay to get a few more
nanoseconds out of the stock market whoa
you know we had the geology people here
and there gets down to brass tacks with
people want do these experimental stuff
they they will back out there you really
have no guts
I mean you surprise me as well too but
I've been crazy user group meetings and
stuff like that yeah I mean now we've
been we've been told so on the side by
vendors that they expect people who can
take risks like the lab yeah to show
them how to move forward because they
don't want to take risk I'm wearing a
microphone I kind of simulation my own
experiences it's it's really hard to get
to get things to be accurate my
experience like a button you know all
quiet back earth to from the hardware
I'm probably pretty happy about it it's
not my question
but because of the hard problem sold so
my question for you is like it is what's
your first about donating this against
hardware and also how you address the
problem of potentially building on
quicksand where may not fully understand
the underlying
voices and their parameters may change
drastically yeah I mean they're many
challenges so for the first part then
there have been fair amount of
simulators that we used today that were
validated once they were released but
then they were modified and who knows
how get there right now that might very
well happen with us I mean we are doing
this validation but it's a challenge and
then we have a little we wanna build up
indeed proven on the shows too right so
it's hard to keep everything as long as
we have a reasonable expectation that
this is it's hard to do you know we've
well we can have yes we can physical
modeling a simulation from a commercial
tool it's the best we can do without
actually paint when they've been out of
it a chip which you're right it would be
more common to have the chip but it's
too early to do that so you could
certainly do that we can do that yes
there are possible funding issues and
many issues there that taping are the
cheapest right but so we're doing the
best we can and it's fairly close but
that is that is a chance for a lot of
hardware we got recently yeah yeah I
mean I told here you but it's like we
have to choose what we take
a father right so it's not only it's not
a little problem
oh yeah native designers were handle you
know building on quicksand where the
underlying device parameters at any time
well that's one of the challenge of
doing research right in some sense I
mean and that happens in other parts
hopefully they will learn the
methodology how to design what they want
using our two floats I said when a new
world arrives they can just run through
the same process again but yes that and
nothing happens I mean we can use
different version to might be very
different and might change things
we just have to run through the flow
again no I mean I do have another idea
that can happen and we have to adjust
and I respond why we're doing this to
flow so we can evaluate all that do we I
apologize we're getting the crotchety in
my old age going back to the remarkable
system with the trillion devices on what
kind of timeframe do you think we would
be in before we were able to fabricate
anything of that complexity ten years
twenty thirty I mean that's if I can
speculate I mean III can say that the
the DARPA program had one of the problem
was actually my functioning and
demonstrating in after silicone in two
or three tape outs I forget silicon of
how many layers was it ten or something
yeah to the order of ten and that was in
the four years
stay all three years some of that okay
so extrapolating to the markable device
that you've got on your screen are you
talking about
the even more remarkable one this one
for instance
yeah or or even the device that you
showed after your talk finished but you
said for example here's I mean these
this would be like 10 15 years out I'd
like to believe that it could be more
based on how quickly other technologies
be developed to make this happen
on this slide I don't see details on
exactly how many devices are involved
right this is more about this this is a
little bit fabricated this is with this
more but I mean what would be this is a
NB memory device I don't see you saying
what this capacity is so saying how long
will take it to advise without saying
what device is it's sort of a shortcut
right well you have it okay this is yeah
this is so this is a concept though so
if we're making how many gigabytes of
per layer three years that is
I mean I it's a manufacturing question
then a little far from right so I'd you
had at the very end and if I count bytes
as being me know there was
hold on I think I had there's something
like 64 games and you know I might be
able to see that in a in five or ten
years why
I think there was 65 64 yeah this is
simple game zone on the rooster Brown
and smaller magnetic Ram in this
particular example same thing we should
be able to say this a in five or eight
years but don't pull me in it because
I'm not a functioning this thing yeah
another fixed point of views like how
can I change the architecture and choose
devices to make this easier this
equation for the foundation people are
funding this research really but it's
not science fiction I think it's more of
a question of when I hope so yeah so one
of the sort of factors that determine
Moore's Law is that these these various
sort of variables and I guess design
feature is sort of improved you know
improve over time and so my question for
you but looking at some of the things
that you're showing here like the number
of layers what seems like a linear
improvement but it's not clear how it's
going to evolve over time although there
might also be you know as you know a
square power improvement due to like
decrease distance for example right and
so my question is how do you foresee
these things evolving over time where is
it just like a a one-time win for 3d
stacking and maybe we'll get an
increment to 10 levels would be stuck
there before we hit the next bottom like
you think okay so that's the question
and it really goes to each of the things
I talked about like specialization I see
it more than one time improvement
because we cannot do better than figure
hardware so we'll get to that who figure
out how to use it how to program it and
then we can't really do any better
the my sister thing will keep improving
and we'll have some your devices so I
think it will still be an improvement
but it might be bumpy it won't be a
smooth curve 3d so hard to say but a
thing it will keep going you know maybe
I'm optimistic about 3d because you know
the devil might be in details and
I certainly know this details but the
thing will keep improving terms of
layers maybe linearly or lessen either
in terms of layers but the impact the
performance might be more than linear
it's hard to say or power and it's also
hard to say about memory I would think
that memory will keep increasing but it
will hit the bottom like at some point
it's hard or a wall how to say how soon
that does that make sense I mean yeah I
mean that doesn't that's exactly why we
we have these tools to keep the scaling
going it one necessary to be smooth but
point is we want to keep going and find
a way to do that so I mean I realize
there are more questions than answers in
this talk and this that's the point of
this talk really is that there's a lot
to do so a to say that will place and
route in 3d essentially yes is what
we're after right I mean I can I don't
know the details but I think it's
something that so
oK we've been talking in a group of how
to build a simulator I'll get to to play
some routing for 3d and it's it's not
that big of a challenge is just a
natural dimension of changing distances
and powers of events placing and routing
will make the problem more complex but
the thing the underlying issues would be
similar but again I'm not another EDA
designer so how long a few years maybe
so I I don't think that's gonna be the
bottleneck
yeah yeah I mean I mean it's it's an
answer I don't know if it's correct but
it's it's my tuition right I don't know
if it's much yours yes what are the
biggest challenges now in carbon
nanotubes well I think bility and
manufacturability in in 3ds one or two
rather virtually here yeah yeah 3d and
and reliability not not a bit not a
question for me but I remember reading
that about about about those transistors
they have improved a lot in past ten
years in both of these aspects and
that's why this demonstration was able
to happen but I think that's still a
bottleneck when we want to scale up
no other questions the same way a change
I had worse go to networks if I want to
get kids from here to there since there
are a rule of thumb for the transition
between copper and fiber in terms of how
slow it is well what that was that was
the other half of the question that one
of the parameters that if I want to go a
long distance it reasonable bandwidth
that's pretty clear that fiber is good
right okay well if I want to go from you
know a couple of feet in the data center
right the expense or the numbers I don't
remember them right now however right
now how it Stiles is that inside the
rock is usually first of all copper and
anywhere outside the rock like from the
top of the rock even do the next right
thing but yeah anywhere further out is
fiber if we so if we look at quarry for
example that's this would be the nurse
right now they have a dragonfly topology
where inside the group it's copper and
outside the group is fiber yeah so the
expectation is that fibers going to be a
better idea for shorter distances with
time right because of better conversion
but we'll see what but I'm thinking
about the people who are gonna use these
devices
what should I wonder if sort of how we
should be training future users of these
devices you might mist under computer
science or
I'm in Stanford and then graduated maybe
they've seen C and Java and web
applications maybe some football
ooh that does some parallel but then all
the sudden ER there you know thrown in
abilities bazzara esoteric devices and
don't know what to do with the pending
claim CS dedication to evolve to prepare
people to deal with this sort of
changing post Moore's law kind of world
in these new interesting architectures
and devices or will they have to look
maybe different I'll just handle it
Medical know maybe the will but the
things people need to get used to
heterogeneity in anything right in the
chip in the memories it's actually
pretty so what does Heather didn't a
dude like it makes the cost of doing
something hard it's dependent or no more
thing so I think it would be more
important for people to to to map that
are working to exist to hardware that
they have but the harbor is going to be
more diverse yeah so from the programmer
side they they need to be aware of what
the card looks like
so less function in that sense because
they need to be able to invoke the
hardware that's best for the job right
in terms of devices well this let me
show an example that's carbon atoms now
where's I had a defect slide that shows
the impact of defense okay so one
example of how architecture might change
based on what what resistor we choose is
P fed suit so that's the gate model
space but on versus the drain current
for a tea set and what is basically
showing is that defense are not good at
high voltages but they're good at low
voltages what that means that to take
advance of that you have to run at low
voltages probably low frequencies
therefore we'll have to increase our
peril ISM to take advantage of Defense
so I guess people need to understand the
impact of these choices to the
activation by using Tiffany yeah even
more even more partisan so there might
be so if somebody wants to write the
program that they don't know where it's
gonna run like a different or a
community based hardware we might just
need their more exact way of describing
the program so that it moves better to
the hardware by the compiler
yeah there are secrets that I think
software programmers won't be able to
just one you know bouquet for
traditional CPUs and they're gonna have
to become more like partner programmers
and learn to deal with things like GPUs
and in the late 70s early 80s there was
a very interesting architecture they
built about two dozen and actually went
to the factory in Aurora Colorado is
called the Danelle courthouse have non
seulement processor it was very
interesting about the memory was each
word memory was a hardware some before
it was atomic ended here at the furthest
dozens architect that companies failed
and that became tera which then bought
the Cray name and before that happened
actually I was talking with great guy
and he was sort of unfortunately from
his plane he thought unfortunately this
this is the wave of the future including
time we're gonna have to get to this
nerd have locked on similar for memory
and I mean the first language was
Fortran and if you had a dollar sign in
front of your variable that made it a
semaphore and there's thought that this
long-running debate of lurcher parallel
computing which is its parallel
computing any easier or harder that
regular whatever regular computing and
we're a bunch of people said now like so
different like Anita Jones at Carnegie
Hall anything else
there are other people like Jim McGraw
over at Livermore who wrote a paper
about this and said yes it's order of
magnitude harder because you run into
deadlock Hawkins or other
for real programs as opposed to awkward
sisters and stuff and you know it would
remove somebody actually did make a few
educational machines like that didn't
help or help so you run into these these
really annoying problems and that's real
research that's trial and error it yeah
you would eat debug just because some
word and memory is empty and you forgot
in thousands of lines of code that you
forgot to initialize it to something
other than zero it's it's a real it's a
real headache by the way I I found the
paragraph recording worse at exactly
what he said if you want to hear it oh
yes I'm okay okay so he Gordon borrowed
the complexity of minimum component
costs has increased at a rate of roughly
a factor of two per year certainly over
the short term this rate can be expected
to continue if not to an increase this
is 19th April 1965 is writing this over
the long term over long term Walker term
the rate of increase is a bit more
uncertain although there is no reason to
believe that it will not remain nearly
constant for at least 10 years
this means 1975 the number of components
per integrated circuit for minimum cost
will be 65,000 then the let their next
paragraph just I just put the one
sentence I believe that such a large
circuit can be built on a single wafer
but yeah I think it's very important
that the Elector that we need to know
what what what hardwood will program
before or just do a good job
you